منهجيه التي تتعامل بها مع هذا مع هذه
الماده العلميه وتوظيفها في البحث العلمي
المنهجيه منهجيه علميه بحته من ناحيه
المسح المصادر واخذ كافه الروايات وبعدين
عرضها على
محكه التحقيق والمقارنه بين الروايات
وقرنها بالدلالات التاريخيه الاخرى
وكذلك في جان مهم السياقه المعنوي للنص
لانه في كثير من النصوص ادخل عليها ما ليس
فيها منحوله منحوله
وحتى انه يعني الكثير من همم الابيات اللي
دخلت على النصوص بغرض معين او نتيجه تشابه
بعض النصوص مع النصوص سعد يعني بعض الناس
يقول لك في القصائد اللي تتشابه وزنا
وتتشابه قافيه ويمكن بعض الاغراض في يمكن
تفهم ان تتدخل النصوص خاصه ما في توثيق
علمي اذا الروايه شفويه في الغالب يعني
الا بعض المخطوطات القليله يعني اللي كانت
موجوده في بعض الامراء او بعض عليت القوم
يعني هذا جانب خلينا نقول لجانب العفوي
المؤسف طبعا المفروض يكون فيه لكن هل في
جانب متعمد
لتحريف او اضافه او تزييف بعض الابيات لا
نخلي مسؤوليه بعض الجهات الخارجيه في نصوص
معينه اقرب دليل القصيده تنسب الى حميدان
الشويعر او قرينيس همم راعي الحريق
السعوديه
وذكر احداث معينه انتصار
همم الامام عبد العزيز بن محمد بن سعود في
معركه ثرمداء وغيرها اشارات معينه ولكن
ادخل في نصوص اخرى ابيات همم مسيئه على
همم
على الانسان حميدان
والخطا الاخر النفس الابيات يدخل على النص
اخر ونسب القرينيس لانهم تشابهم في نفس
الاسلوب الشعري
وما زال همم يزيدون في الابيات هذه لحد
قريب يعني الى انه يزيدون عليها ويعدلون
الشيعه هذا طيب هذا يقودنا ايضا الى موضوع
اخر انا اذكر ما مندوب من ذكر اسماء بعض
المراكز التي نشات مؤخرا تقول عن نفسها ان
تهتم بتاريخ الجزيره العربيه من خارج
السعوديه
على التاريخ السعودي المحلي سواء الوقائع
الحربيه والمعارك
والاحداث معينه ليس بغرض همم علمي بريء
نعم بل باغراض اخرى اللي تعرف الماده
التاريخيه تجيش احيانا صحيح خاصه انها
تحتل جزء من الذاكره
حول
في عام
1431 قال فيها الشيخ هذا انه صيانه تراثنا
الثقافي من العبث لان نجد مثلا في جهات
دول اخرى همم ربما تكون شقيقه
يمارسون همم حريه كامله في التعاطي في
تراثنا الادبي بما يتناف همم يتعارض مع
الوحده الوطنيه واثاره انهارات او
التزوير والتزهير اهداف معينه وكان
المفترض ان همم كنت مقترح فيها المقال هذا
انه يرقد تعامل مع التراث الثقافي الى
مستوى رسمي من وزاره الثقافه وزاره
الخارجيه انه يعتبر شان داخلي لا يتم
تناوله من اي دوله اخرى الا باذن من
الجهات المعنيه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واخذ الاذن لان هذا يخصنا ما هو
يخص
نجد بعض الباحثين يتجنب التطرق الى تراثه
ثقافي او ما فيه من نتوءات معينه ولكنه
يجد انه شيء مباح له ان يتناول بحريه
كامله وتطبع الكتب او تصدر الفيديوهات او
المسلسلات في اليوتيوب
انت مالك سلطان موجودين بره سواء عندهم
نوايا مبيت سياسيه او والله حابب تعرف
السوق السعودي سوق كبير حابب يشتهر في
السوق السعودي
بما ان الناس تهتم بتاريخها هذول اللي بره
ما علينا منه
للبيت رب يحميك كما قيل يعني احنا احنا
كسعوديين هل تعتقد ان احنا لدينا تقصير في
الاهتمام العلمي في هذه الماده ال ال ال
ال الماده الادب الشعبي ان كان شعرا او
مرويات وسواليف كما يقال يعني
[موسيقى]
اول قبل لا تناول هذا يجب ان تتولى وزاره
الثقافه مسؤوليهتها ما نترك الاخرين نرقد
تعامل معهم من انه شان داخلي ويفهمون هذا
الحساب بنضع حد لهذا التجاوز اما من
ناحيتنا هنا المراكز الثقافيه همم
والاهتمام وهمم من وزاره الثقافه برده انا
احط المسؤوليه امام وزاره الثقافه
اهتمت بكل شيء واهملت الجانب الادب الشعبي
الان عندنا انا اتكلم لك اني حققت خلال
الفتره الزمنيه من القرن الخامس الهجري
والرابع الهجري الى همم القرن الثاني عشر
الهجري ما يفوق 700 مقال نشرته الرياض او
في مجلات علميه اخرى
عندي كم هائل من المخطوطات ومن النتائج
اللي يجب ان يحفظ ويراعى سواء كنت بهانه
ويقوم به جهه مسؤوله تعطي هذا الاهتمام لا
يهمل لانه تركه همم هكذا اول شيء معرض
للتزييف معرض ان للتوظيف للتوظيف الاخر
ثاني شيء اذا كنا قادرين على ان نتعاطى مع
خلافه هذه بعد سنوات ما في احد يقدر
يتعاطى معه
فانا ما زلت من ذو المقال السابق اللي قبل
يمكن همم 1431 الان وطالب واكرر مطالبه في
ان يجب ان تقوم وزاره الثقافه بهذا الجانب
المهم
توثيق الادب همم دراسه وتحقيق النصوص
الشعريه اللي تهتم بحياه اهل جزيره العرب
في جهود الباحثين سواء الاوائل زي مثلا
ابن خميس همم اللي هم دونوا النعده
بالشعبي وغيره من مدير الفهيد وغيرهم او
اللي درسوه بشكل اكاديمي زي سعد صويان
يعني يوظفوه بس هذه تظل جهود فرديه يعني
جهود باحثين هل في مؤسسات معنيه بهذا
الامر همم من قبل سيبك من قبل تاليف وزاره
الثقافه لان حديثه وزاره حديث فيه اداره
الملك عبد العزيز واتجاهها الان حسب توجيه
خادم الحرمين الشريفين طول عمره في وضع
همم قسم همم الشعر العام في موسوعه الملك
عبد العزيز الشعر العربي هذه خطوه رائده
لكنها ما وجدنا اخرى الان وضع اني همم
تولى موضوع تاريخ الدوله السعوديه الاولى
والثاني من خلال الشعر همم العامه برده
خطوه اخرى لكن احنا نبيه في اطار رسمي
مستمر ما هو ان يقوم باحث ان انت دوره لا
يجب ان يكون مرجعيه كامله وفي اي نصوص وفي
اجازه النصوص